はい定義で始まりましたはじめ社長のエンディング発表会後編ということでございます
前編まだ見てない方は是非動画概要欄のリンクからご覧くださいませ全便欠航あのまだ
まともっと言いますからついつい笑顔になっちゃいエンディングが多かったと思うん
ですけども
後半わー
動いですよと言えるさっそく見ていきましょう
後半戦どうぞよ
えっマットでしょ
またねおいは変わっており変わったねそれもちょっと上手いし
ちゃんとうまいし叩かなやつ
すごい
おおおお
をシンプルかつ短いいいねん
もうすぐ可愛い
まあねすなぁ
さや線撥油ネクターが俺じゃありません
ああああああ
いやー
い
にゃふ
まっ
オレカエ
フィンいいいね
ピンッ
5ああっちゃー
めちゃくちゃ丁寧に作られている4すごい
浮気きれい
絶対こういう上手なの作れる語って映像のなんかされていたかったので本当にすごいと
思う
かわいい
あーところさん寝ちゃったーーーー
[音楽]
わーのほほん
かわいい
もうゲームっぽいなぁいいよ
[音楽]
柵木ゲームぽくおら好きですよ
のかわいいゲーム
すごい
[音楽]
大汗やっぱなんかゲームの8ビットに水が音声があるんだろうなぁ
結果こよっ
かっこよええ
なにこのペル育っカーン
でかっこいいへ
すごいページわかっちゃったよわれまですごいすごい
一いい
いやもうぶそうそー
[音楽]
あのーテーマ名だけますけど俺
ねぇもうありがとうよ
もうすごい音楽はそのままな
ねええええ待って何これ
えっ
すごくね
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばい鳥肌立った用語
家は未だ13つリアルとして今何か色々とかこの俺から限界みたいな歓声がすごかった
そうでいつご
生まれ我慢ですちょっとはねませんだオレはー
俺か
ねっ残念イラッこれすごくだけで作られたみたいです
バッハ
aan まずん
水あっ
すごいなぁ
ねえほれこれスローで使ったん
えっすごいすごいゲームじゃん
えっ
[音楽]
寝ちゃうのをそのまま
テレビみんねぇ
で布団で
すげえなんだこのレベル
この短い制作時間でよくこんなん作りホント
うわぁ動いてる動いてる3 d で動いてノレがー
いやいうすごいすごい
いやいや逆椋子
ええっ
すごい
ウォッチ
[音楽]
すごいよなんなのこのレベルー
ねっ
なんかすぐ北にあるあの感じが出てるすごい
[音楽]
俺か
馬は
これはすごい
かわいい
くっ
おうわーーー
[音楽]
だからもうもやし食ってるしすごい
かわいいコントローラーも同じ色だし俺のーと
[音楽]
うげーーーーー
ゆっ
では行こうまとめてたよ今
もう
かわいい
[音楽]
泣いてる
すればやつうわぁ
でーっ
ええええ
いつぞあに名称
[音楽]
パパがバーバパパ
いやはからねこねこねこいいね恋に来ない方がいいか分かったと思います
だから南へえっなに声
くま
[音楽]
某すごい
をもどうですね
おおおおすごいすごいすごい
ただファンカーバーも畑もありますすばらしい
強いシンプルん
かわいい
東つぶすっ
[音楽]
器具て多いんだね俺はん
恋文字品といいですねえっ
を
[音楽]
すごい地下で見てるんだ俺が
麦田あるから
[音楽]
すごいかわいい凄い凄い事に
オレンジはよくこんな所まで見てもらって言うん
[音楽]
ua
うすごいうわかっこよええ
しゃべてねー
すごい北半動画を見てくれ
する上から皆さん seo メイクさん
これ俺
[音楽]
言われてみればぽいですけど
4回の最後
いや
猿
スマホだ
うすごい
上飛び出す1人だけ
上すごいよ
いやー水力作るな本当に
たいしたもんですありがとうございます凄い
どっいっ
美少ねぇ
[音楽]
かわいい
まあ
いやまた音が同額を買っ
壮大なんだけだ
規模
まさかバーン
地球から出てくるのは今までありがとうバンカーん
かっこいい
大
いやまず al うまいなぁ本当に皆さん
すごいなぁ
[音楽]
いや
a 4
いやいや
stay
分
机合わないん
これボクかー
見てるなぁ
姉のすごいすごいすごいめっちゃ可愛いほんととか
アート喘息ん
うんえっすごい沿い筋トレする
えっ
須郷マジこのクオリティ
[音楽]
復帰する
はっはっは
いやいやーを開くメア
え
a 風そっち
まあすごいすごいすごい
俺の切られた前髪 the それ
ヤバ目の付け所がすげーシャープだな
悪阻
某労働省みたいんですけど
恋移動
俺が前街ある時だお
かわいい
素敵なイラスト
うん
かわいい
大
[音楽]
itf だぞ当てて増えてないか
あれあれあれ
もう可愛い
わーで方任せるの立つ日すごいいいですね
うわぁこれもう全部いいじゃーん
プロげっっ
バーがいい
[音楽]
かわいい
不安スコップティピ3がすごい
ただ違いまあすごいインパクト凄いっすよこれ
あっはぁん
すごいファイナルファンタジーっぽいエース号
すごい
を得た枷になったん
すげーこれフェル5から5のペットっぽいな
いやや買うんだ俺ファイナルファンタジー5めっちゃ好きなんで1反応しました
ん
グッ
かっこいい
[音楽]
や素敵なすごいよ
ああすごい2
二えーっ
[音楽]
プレーヤーモード
もうアニメやーん
[音楽]
あとござ
いやすごいやっぱゲームのイメージが追加の俺
ドアを開けてくれてる
うんびっくりした最後何が起きたかと思ったん
やばい表えっ
何何このレベルこの入るブルー
はじめしゃちょーう
長くないさあ良い予行もうほんと最後らへんですよこれ
うわぁ
[音楽]
すごい
ただね6月切って大魔王しブーン
うわすげぇ俺の建物住んでる家の屋上と全く一緒
を畑なすごいすごいすごいすごいかわいいも皆さん制すが本当にある
[音楽]
いやすぅ5位すごい
ベンリーグサーもこれアニメの
[音楽]
水ラーをすごいです本当にええええ
ウイッグかな
この2見たん
[音楽]
とはいいこれで後ろに人絶対見えるんだろうなぁ
はいというわけでいかがだったでしょうかがもうれベール方が入ってきも何前回はそう
だったんですけど今回も本当にもうアニメのエンディング見てんじゃないかみたいな
ものもあったし決してくれて戦いを得ないんですけどめちゃくちゃ面白いもとても多く
て圧的なエンディングたくさん作っていただいて本当にありがとうございました
そんなのから一つ選ぶっていうのは本当に心苦しいんですけども
今
皆様が3ターン
てユニークなんだから一つだけ今後のはじめ者さんは動画のエンディングとして使わせ
ていただくものを
決めたいと思いますというも決まっております
こちら
[音楽]